los republicanos se hacen notar en la
cámara de representantes y este martes
hicieron valer su mayoría para expulsar
a la demócrata y la nahumar de la
comisión de asuntos exteriores de la
cámara
para ser claros una representante puede
decir lo que quiera pero no tenemos que
aceptarlo las personas que tienen
opiniones tan odiosas deberían ser
excluidas de este tipo de comité
los republicanos achacan a Omar seis
declaraciones especialmente un tuit de
2019 que Omar borró y por el que después
se disculpó el tuit decía que todo se
trata de los benjamins una referencia al
billete de 100 dólares de Benjamin
Franklin con el que insinuaba que Los
partidarios de Israel Solo piensan en el
dinero Omar se defendió
no en el congreso para guardar silencio
vine el congreso para hacer su voz y mi
liderazgo y mi voz No disminuirán si no
estoy en este comité por un periodo mi
voz será más y más fuerte y mi liderazgo
será celebrado en todo el mundo como lo
ha sido
la expulsión se suma a la negativa del
líder de la mayoría republicana Kevin
mccarthy a que los demócratas erickwell
y Adam shift hagan parte de la comisión
de inteligencia decisiones vistas como
retaliaciones por las expulsiones de los
republicanos Marjorie Taylor Green y
Paul gozar en 2021 cuando los demócratas
tenían mayoría por retórica incendiaria
los compañeros de Omar salieron en su
defensa
colegas me presento ante ustedes como
una orgullosa judía y una orgullosa
amiga y colega de Ilan Omar
Omar llegó a Estados Unidos como
refugiada desde somalia es la única
congresista nacida en África y una de
las pocas mujeres musulmanas de la
cámara de representantes forma parte de
los nueve representantes demócratas
conocidos Como de Squad por su carácter
progresista y por su juventud